welcome back to Minecraft on steroids
Jesus I'm here with the false spend not
even a blink huh
alright well all there you are I'm sorry
I'll come back for you one day oh god
don't look at me like that I'll come
back one day don't worry I'll save you
it will all be okay oh God
escape escape oh all right so welcome
back to Minecraft on steroids everyone
this is awesome
this is where I died excuse me hey hey
hey hey hey illegal illegal what the
hell is wrong with them are you gonna
attack me or not I just want my stuff oh
god stop dumb oh yeah this is I would do
it in Sweden we fight people from a
distance and we're we're safe it takes a
lot of bravery it takes a lot of courage
but most of all it takes a lot of
meatball done cool that was epic yes yes
haha
easy this game is easy people complain
this game is hard can you believe it I
can't I swear I had a sword there it is
there you are
now let's say let's say Oh God
Oh Oh Shiva loose mobile he says I've
been digging straight down I don't even
give up brick here we go Iren are you
kidding me I can't
[Music]
how do I get that level for what
Fairless flint pickaxe is that a flint
pickaxe lovely sounds coming from down
over under oh god I didn't think it
would fit okay close my eggs maybe he
doesn't see me oh please I need Spain I
was genuinely terrifying so far zero
deaf gamers so far we're good that was a
close call
not gonna lie though I was just chillin
I was just vibing and then big giant
diamond darkness engaged in me it's cool
we need what is this oh yeah we have the
meat from them we need Flint
that's lava all right I don't
there's Flint but the demon is right
there
all right I have wool maybe back cover
up yeah but he can't come through now
haha
stink alright should not press my luck
huh Flint Chardon first try baby damn it
I realized we need to I need to get some
sticks hello hey hey hey hey
no think it's teleport he can teleport I
got him I got him I got him again
Oh God focus focus
use the sweetest strength am i even
damaging him I don't think I am I'm just
too scared chop chop chop chop - oh I
did it I defeat the demon Oh
oh my heart is pounding like a Bing bong
aunt and their poster whoo let's get our
Flint Flint is minting hey Sven
hey fake false when you'll never believe
what I got he better still be there most
van for Sven don't jump don't jump don't
jump oh thank god one day I'll make you
mine false man stay there
I'll bet sleep okay so I just need to
grab some sticks from the trees because
this is apparently how you do it in this
game-mode grabbing sticks from tree
branches I know
mix makes no sense all right we got a
couple what in the God's earth is that
is that a monkey ahh bra that's a
frickin epic monkey dude I'm not gonna
go near it
hey bones I can team i contain bone me
no wait Oh what am i doing I needed a
bones you're stinky you stinky brain Oh
God ah I'm sorry Spenny
ah damn I'm dumb all right can I taste
the moon the moon cake num num num num
num no a make some speed doesn't heal me
de all right gamers let's make a pickaxe
how do you do it
flinch are for Flint shards
that is not Chupacabra I don't freak we
shoot by cameras oh no it's a freaking
super camera I'm prepared to take this
to the Battle of the end of the world in
another life though in another life
though God everything sucks
yes sting dumb body once told me your
stump they look lovely something let me
slur don't attack me evil dragon just
having a Slurpee I swear this whole mod
feels like a Minecraft fever dream I'm
not sure I like it or not but I made a
promise to spend damn it I will tame him
just need link there it is I've got it
what's up Belle Delphine alright let's
toss this yep and now gamers we can
finally make a flint pickaxe mmm yes
it's mining time gamers there it is what
does that mean for for what you can make
numchucks
oh I can make num shoots right now
actually prioritise I got them
stone nunchucks yeah oh so do I level up
the pickaxes is that what happens okay I
think I got it so you can level up your
skills
there's farming so I need more in mining
then I can smash obsidian oh god I don't
even want to know what the nether is
like so how do I level up oh I'm doing
it mi6 let's try it yes and I don't even
have to use the crappy one there it is
whoa yes after oh yeah
cool that's so cool it's like an RPG now
you can level up and stuff
I love the leveling up stuff it makes me
feel less worthless as a human being in
real life when my fake online character
is better at least I can improve that
myself
I don't like improving myself I think
I'll stick to my fictional video game
character that will be fun for maybe
sorry gamers was that too real for you I
used to be so addicted to World of
Warcraft I mean everyone was that game
was drugs but it comes to time in
everyone's life gamers where you got to
realize am I having fun or am I just
wasting time for me was what I had maxed
out my World of Warcraft characters like
you could literally not improve anything
of it it had the best ring it had the
best trinket and had the best everything
and I have just like perfected it and I
would spend time like maximizing my
skillset and what the hell is this ah me
to level up something else this is the
level of magic maybe I'll take some
magic can I do it now we are magic magic
magic so so I started making a new
character and then like after a couple
levels I'm like what am i doing I don't
think I need to be too sad alright come
on I don't know what's gonna happen I
broke it
damn it maybe I should have used my
nunchucks real life craft veterans was
cringing that whole time that I just
mined diamonds with the stone pickaxe
that I actually just do that whatever I
don't care
yes feelsgoodman
can we actually make some proper armor
now please I'm tired of you being
useless
yeah wait I don't have the required
level defence eight oh man can I at
least make an iron pickaxe okay nice no
I need mining eight what in the world
grappling hook no way that's so cool I
can't with
huh
what in the world just happens huh
it's a tree it's a tree that's coming to
kill me big on tree yeah I can't use it
it's nunchucks now I can't use the dumb
chunks
oh okay stone stones sure yeah
yeah suck it suck a bush yeah suck it
secondly yeah you stink I'm gonna burn
you and then eat you vegan filthy beef
that's what you do this is why we
shouldn't save the environment I'm just
kidding alright I'm just saying the
environment can be dangerous
think about it oh god I got a flow why
do I not get hungry anymore so strange
okay I need to I forgot what I was doing
requires attack 69 420 I see of course
maybe we should just go out and kill
kill stuff if I eat the raw chupacabra
I'll loosen it there's drugs in mine
crap
what alright let's go oh no I take it
back I don't want to explore cool nice
yeah we just need to keep leveling it up
oh my god what is that look I have a
skeleton head what happens if I place it
oh no this is not gonna be good why am i
doing anything I hey let's just see no I
did nothing
Loki conic you maybe I need to place it
somewhere else like like here cool that
looks awesome
okay there's the power over there we can
explore
that is so freaky
whoa whoa
they actually climbed the walls that's
so tricky let me just get rid of these
Oh God
rare spider uh we were all fine a second
ago and then now this happened look at
him
rare cave spider of Chris penis what's
in the chest though
Loki what's in the chest what so quickly
how oh it's got one shot at dude cool
that was definitely worth it absolutely
this is like when you started off
playing Minecraft all over again cuz you
don't know what's rare a light doused
wow that's so epic what what is this
whoa Oh spooky hello huh trap it's a
trap
Oh you tried to trick that trickster I
don't all right we need to kill the bone
man that's all we got to do at this
point yes and Sven is gonna look so epic
all right let's find a bone man
what if I can kill them I don't think
I'm damaging it oh wow
revenge revenge yes
cowards oh you can do headshots cool
I've gained knowledge about them by
killing them Becca
all right it's dark I want to go home oh
wait can I level up or should I a little
up agility maybe building Oh freaking
tumbleweed scared me god damn tumbleweed
there's one there's a skeleton
ah okay No ah you took everything from
me Jesus what's happening want you to
fricken aah
Jesus Lord
oh my god I literally just had to sleep
oh my god leave me alone leave me alone
I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
I they don't do any damage and then they
do all the damage explain that
scientists all right that's good enough
that's good enough for me
oh I lost the bones I need Sven and I
need their wolf armor as well
oh my I hate clanks I broke my mouse
again Swedish engineering always works
oh yeah that's where I walk away clink
walk away no no maybe I can lure him
away
come here clinky clinky stinky
hey come here clinky dumb hey what are
you even throwing what is it this water
why does he give me a yeah
hey plink my man clink man missed me
plink I'll stop giving me yet
all right yes thanks for nothing Belle
Delphine oh look at the figures
attacking everyone oh yes love us all
right do I have the wolf armor no I lost
it I lost it in the great a faggio war
spent my may you want a bone
he loves me I'm dying of hypothermia
because you warned my heart little one
I'll be right back it's a little hot in
here oh yeah I can use my bow and arrow
now maybe we can do that to love a look
hey look as a oh why did I die
Sarah that run all right gamers let's do
it all right how much XP does a
get dragon bones sword that's so cool
Halbert ayran halliburton oh we should
make that Pole and wool oh my lord I'm
so sorry
is that a mother flippin diamond what
what how all right let's kill some
jousts blop damn the arrow is amazing
crunch okay alright
yes now we can level up our attack and
then by the end of the day we'll have a
mother flippin ayran Halbert oh god
that's epic damn one shot kill baby what
is this whoa the blood moon rising oh my
god is sandworms whoa
death to worm why is it called that
because it's dead
Oh God oh Jesus
shush shush by Satan by Satan don't what
you I do this every day before I go to
sleep it's normal
thanks Satan okay go oh it's just blood
moon it happens what in the world was
that
I just got dude it on I just got mother
flipping dude it on can I kill these
giant oh I bet he's gonna drop a lotta
XP
he's gonna die in front of his wife
pathetic
laughable yes give me that XP and now
I'll freak his wife
that's one dice oh he drop a banana and
it looks like AB I don't know what the
vegetable is called but yeah whatever
barely drops any XP woah oh god oh no oh
Oh Oh God
that's a lot of damage I'm glowing I'm
literally glowing crazy no bye-bye
ha ha dum wha what okay can I stay in
here I'm scared
Oh mending nice I mean it can't be that
bad it's just a Sandstrom oh yeah maybe
we can kill the giant skeleton wizard
thing from very afar wait can I not
shoot him with arrows I can't why that's
so cool
sorry hey look it's your mummy sorry
hey don't dodge ah how many times have I
died so far in this playthrough zero
thanks for asking
it's like when I don't want to die I get
a freaking tiger dragon in my face but
now I'm actually looking for enemies I
keep getting hyper thermos it's not
ethic oh cool we did it we did it we did
it yes
screw this I'm making a freakin halibut
good Jesus
oh no way attack the guard
[Applause]
you'll never get me here goddamn trees
oh my god is that all I needed
coal we made a pole now we make a helper
yes now Mia Sven fake Sven we're gonna
get the flippin out of here come on
follow me
I got a frickin helper that's so cool
I'm done I'm done
we're leaving Sven we got to find the
new home where we don't always have to
worry about overheating
whoa we found the source of the bath
water impressive what is that all right
Sven follow my lead whoop damn it
then oh god I forgot how slow he is at
swimming
oh come on Sven you have legs you can't
swim oh oh whoa it's like an Aztec
temple don't drink the water Sven it's
the most poisonous source of all time
you'll get herpes instantly trust me you
don't want gamer girl herpes not epic
okay enchantment table what what lives
here I think this is them the witches
but it's a very confused I really need
to drink tonight Oh God
my father warned me not to drink things
the bath water but I have no choice I'm
too thirsty
van Damme
let's explore the temple you never know
what you're gonna get but I know I'm
strong enough to defend myself
well I need one block like a second is
that the entrance or it is the entrance
careful spine this is extremely
dangerous
what on God's earth is this well that
was a waste of time
all right watch this van never mind oh
god what's attacking me what is
attacking me a bi e then why did I spawn
here your bed was obstructed oh my god
he has to toot van I don't know about
this he's got the toot oh yeah get his
toot get his tooth get it get it get it
did you drop it
damn it I wanted this toot who are you
looking at
who are you I hate you I well this is
not too bad of a house we can stay here
spend what what ah alright come at me oh
that's what I thought go away come at me
then come on eat your own poop
yeah oh my god pufferfish if it didn't
look derpy enough before
hey the golden eat girl sorry
sorry rainforest sorry that you suck so
much
yeah look at that is a big tree going
down oh oh oh okay this is good this is
our home let's just take out all these
stupid treats what just happened oh no
I'm gonna die
alright at least I spawn in the house
damn this thing slays pathetic oh god
yes yeah I'm the alpha
yeah I'll kill a baby dumb babies Oh God
okay am i playing Minecraft or Oh God
not the water oh yeah haha dumb that's
what I'm talking about
apparently my camera froze that's it I'm
adding that video there hope you guys
enjoyed smash like check out merch see
you next time
what you haven't tried to pursue malade
accessory after 50 million outros my
etch down just now it's still relevant
just download it